hi there reject nation it's Greg Alba
here and I'm John well with a bunch of
reactions in movie reviews I'm seeing a
lot of comments coming going what are
you gonna do another try not to laugh
challenge I know we rarely do those the
reason reaction videos existed in the
first place here's how life works
sometimes in this field sometimes Tyrone
looks at our Channel
sometimes I look at his I loved on stage
[Music]
[Music]
okay this is about like that you know
just to piss me off
how would you describe this
versions of things are
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
get away you sick you did you're coming
any closer yours mistaken as a freaking
psycho
okay the fishing boats will be in soon
we'll fly behind them and scream like
hell and whatever they throw overboard
we get to eat
maybe we should just get our own food
you know we have beaks we can swim
instead of scrounging off of others
maybe cut you from him what was that
what was that you want to be a hawk is
that what to it because you're not
alright even clutching towns down there
look we have webbed feet
paddle your food to death with your wet
feet look I just I thought you thought
how's that working out for you not very
well very well
what are these
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we did it we did it
did you did you did you pop a gasket
trying not to laugh there yeah there was
a couple of times I really got I really
are some some good bits and some you're
like stone cold ice I take this very
serious partly to as I've seen half
these bits before I don't remember most
of these bits there were some of them i
weirdly wanted to laugh a little harder
at the ones I was actually more familiar
with like that quagmire one is just a
bit I've like pulled up on YouTube oh
yeah billion times with the Discovery
internet pornography yeah sometimes I'll
be like remember that they're family you
haven't heard that bit from Family Guy
let me pull it up order who did they
don't laugh that's funny well in the
comedy of that one is like just in the
way he's so like quiet and flush like
she was not used to hearing quagmire in
that state of mind Michael Jackson
honestly the first one was the closest I
got to being like I don't know if I
would be able to make through this yeah
what starts like shooting pretty close
to busting us I have never seen this one
with this sheet I've definitely never
seen the uncensored version of that one
as I was watching I was like partially
getting pulled out thinking how does
this sound on Fox can any of these jokes
just a long string of bleep
yeah because they sometimes do that
where's the long string of loose and you
buy the DVDs and they're uncensored like
oh wow there's a lot of swearing in here
[ __ ] I love their long drawn-out
cutaways those are my favorite ones just
keep going I like some I like that
tendency generally although this was
actually not one of my favorites of
those I kind of didn't have a hard time
being like I'm ready for this bit to be
that was so funny
why don't we stream by the end yeah
the seagull the the transition from the
dock into the office I thought was
really funny
yeah but the Cookie Monster one's just a
classic bit yeah oh no over the kidney
stones
oh yeah and I wanted to seem like the
surrounding context of that joke dude
like that was one that was yeah fresh to
me I almost couldn't keep together yeah
well hey
but this in mind I wanted to give a
patron on the day shout-out to someone
named Derek Mitchell Derek I'm
constantly making jokes about how you
look like a serial killer today I'm not
gonna do that I'm gonna do a classic
Greg Alva shoutout where I read to
people the meaning of your name and then
work off of that Derek means gifted
ruler Oh maple ruler jackpot his last
name Mitchell who is like God
wait so you're a people ruler who's
gifted and you're like God that means
you're God God I guess what I've gotten
from this is your parents must be pretty
disappointing you
they named me something like Derek
Mitchell they think that you're gonna be
some crazy noble ruler of people Fisher
of men and what do you do you kidnap
women you throw them in the trunk of
your car and you murder them you sick
pervert it's not very christ-like it's
not very christ-like I doesn't need to
be christ-like it's just not God like
well it depends on which God probably
living right up to that name I don't
know your good vision if we're going
Greek right now maybe you know I guess
congratulations you live up to your name
yeah I keep keep keep it up I suppose
this will be calling writing a character
arc I have had the character of oh yeah
you fully I well from judging him and
thinking he's not God like two realizing
there are other religions and we have to
accept that there's many different kinds
of beliefs out there and I have accepted
the fact hey if you kill people that's
part of your faith yeah and then who are
we to judge cuz we didn't you know yes
Alice John I'm not doing improv bit
yes no cultural relativism sir
that's what Family Guy does definitely
always always a sincere program full of
wholesome and worthwhile ideas but on a
serious note start killing some men
equality we're in a very specific time
right now with all these movements and
stuff start killing some men well why
not start killing some guns like this
able-bodied men you keep treating this
like it's an improv bit speak from the
heart you know Derek III I just I'm
really ready to commit my everlasting
soul to you that's I mean my life has
been devoid of purpose and meaning for
so long and this is just a lot of
information for me to take in so really
I'm just afraid to express my true
feelings which is you know just add you
Latian and adoration for you and I don't
really I want to cry right now because
of your intense beauty I just think of
you and I hear this choir and this white
light and my life starts to make a
little bit more sense than it did before
and you know that's something I've never
felt before and I've never had to convey
via a shout-out but you know Derek it
all makes sense tell fan Thanks
I don't know you